but i remember there was one time we
were in your studio you farted and i
lost my [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ]
did you [ __ ] fart yeah bruh
hold up hold up hold up hold on can we
appreciate something only a garbage ass
human would fart behind you and be like
that wasn't me who else was it
who else was it no but maybe
because we all know people like that who
far beside you trying to look at you
confused like what did he smell me [ __ ]
you know
you can smell you
no but don't look confused that's what
i'm saying but i think that they owned
it because i know you owned it but i
thought maybe it would okay i was like
maybe it's his chair maybe it's the
floor
some of the chairs make weird noises you
know i mean frank
i like
[ __ ] did you fart and i was wishing it
was i wasn't sure i was really wishing
that [ __ ] it was wishful thing
did you fart yeah
like what
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you gotta you gotta be honest with me we
working this [ __ ] i don't wanna smell
your insides but think about me [ __ ] is
wrong with you think about how many
times we filmed it for how long the fact
that i don't do it that often is a sign
of respect
no
no that one time you know what i'm
saying like
go to the bathroom and the bathroom is
right there get up go in the bathroom
god damn you working in this [ __ ] i
don't want to be smelling your insides
i'm gonna
look like [ __ ] y'all remember the
first time y'all y'alls
smelt a woman fart
yeah
wasn't that weird yeah
for sure why is it weird
because i think the way i perceived
women up until that point was like
you never think about women farting and
[ __ ] like obviously you
intellectually you probably know what
depends on what kind of porn you watch
definitely didn't watch that kind of
point so for me it just wasn't a thing
you know so once i realized that there's
like women can be just as disgusting as
men it really changed my perception yeah
yeah i may be linked it to you know what
if you [ __ ] if your [ __ ] could fart
you fart
[ __ ] farts are funny
yeah that's just the fun part it's
entertainment
for the whole family [ __ ]
for the whole fat dog what is the whole
family doing in there
the [ __ ] is wrong with you what do you
do with your girl hey kids got around
the funny thing that's the most
wholesome i don't know
i agree i think what kills me about
[ __ ] farts is always the woman's
reaction afterwards
no it farts and there's quiet and they
go
sorry
every time i always feel terrible about
it you'll be hitting that [ __ ] from
behind just
i'm going to do it again
it's my fault
yeah you sure it sure is your fault you
should have filled this [ __ ] with dick
instead of instead of air hey man
that little pause before is my favorite
you could just hear the attention
sorry
and i've had to have it to me like a
good six seven times really yes
because women are very self-confident
like if you ever like laughed so hard
because it was just perfect
did you almost lose your you know you
got to like get back into it no because
generally i'm pretty into it so yeah no
i tried to replicate you want to know a
time where i lost my my [ __ ] in bed
because they said something
it hasn't
oh we're about to get a story we're
about to get a story i was in it and you
know sometimes i'd be doing some dirty
talking but nothing too extreme
and uh
remember i said something like yo
that shit's good right and she's like
yeah i'm like is this the best you ever
had she's like nah not really
[Laughter]
wow
cause she was like oh not really
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was so funny oh my god wasn't
even bad
that's funny i wasn't even mad that's
funny
and i was crying bro that's funny i i
had to stop then at that point i stopped
right
that's just pure comedy right there
that's just pure comedy
not really that's just funny
i like being stunned you like it why is
it the best you ever had
she had to think back and be like one
time well at least at least she was
honest you know that whatever whenever
you said whenever you said do you like
it and she said yeah she was actually
saying the truth it was just not the
best you ever got like she lives in a
great time but honesty is
i've definitely had this is it is it the
best you ever had no i give it a 8.
that [ __ ] had me rolling for days
and i i wasn't bad at all that she
killed
guys that was a good moment that's
probably all the time but queefs
generally like my experience is that
women are already like very
self-conscious when they're in bed or
whatever position that they're in so
anything like that that they do they
they feel uncomfortable about it because
they think they've made things worse so
try to be a little bit understanding and
be like not make it awkward just a week
i'd like to just start calling them
queen laquifa
i don't know why but i've definitely
read this somewhere
queen
yeah i feel like i've heard that
somewhere somewhere okay queen like
okay we look we heard so many play play
on words with queen louise yeah yes
i've definitely heard
people talking [ __ ] about her being like
whatever laquifa